Du känner dig inte utvald i termer av att du får en rabatt, utan det är 20% ner men det är lite såhär, du har ingen uppfattning om vad priset var innan och det står ett nytt pris och du får det priset som står och det bara blir lite såhär ja okej.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl generationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkomna, vi är Jakob Wibon-Westerberg, kan det vara poddens mest välkända namn nu efter, detta blir fjärde avsnittet.
Jag ska inte säga att jag är trött på dig, men jag tyckte ju mer om dig för fyra och en halv timme sedan när vi satt oss här i poddstudion.
Hur känner du inför mig?
Jag är fortfarande helt okej med dig.
Det gäller att hitta, det gäller att vara en stor haj, en liten ankdam och nu är jag kanske den mest välkända namnen till Make Sweden Stronger.
Det är ändå härligt att få vara en stor fisk där åtminstone.
En väldigt liten plattform.
Ja, det är du, min mamma och min kompis som lyssnar på den här podden.
Men jag tänkte att i det här avsnittet så betar vi av punkter i ganska högt tempo, som är lite random, det är kanske inte lika stora punkter som de vi har pratat igenom innan.
Men jag tänker att vi bara kör på, det är ingen som vill höra vår livshistoria.
Om vi ska diskutera tredje parts logistik kontra eget lager, vem ska ha vilket och finns det någon fördel med de olika?
Har du någon åsikt?
Jag har en åsikt för jag har eget lager, jag vet att du inte tycker samma.
Nej men snarare såhär, det här är väl nästan inte ens en diskussion för några varumärken utan alla kör ju tredje parts lager.
Det är ju bara du som kör eget lager.
Jag ser...
Rugvista har eget lager.
Absolut.
Jag ser stora vinster i eget lager, jag tror att det finns en stor fördel med det.
Jag tror att ganska få bolag kan ha det på ett effektivt sätt när de är små.
Lite lättare då när man är lite större, men jag tror att man ska försöka hålla sig bortifrån sådana grejer.
Ibland har man en bolag som slår ihop och kör lager tillsammans med två andra varumärken.
Jag tror att det som är gjort för att det ska bli kaos.
Men om man någonstans på vägen känner att nu är vi tillräckligt stora för att kunna operera i ett eget lager, så tror jag att det finns stora vinnningar i det.
Det går att hitta effektivitet, det går att få ner kostnaderna, det går att skapa en bättre upplevelse för slutkund.
Ni kanske inte är ett sånt bolag nödvändigtvis, men det går att skriva handskrivna kort och få in lite mer av den där touchen in i leveransen som är ganska svårt att få till med tredjepatch logistiklösningar.
Jag tänkte just det där med att man ska skriva kort.
Det säger folk ibland som att det är någon sorts fördel med eget lager.
Det måste vara typ den minsta fördelen som finns med eget lager.
Har inte SNs eget lager?
De köpte en egen fastighet tror jag som de ska skicka eget.
För de har redan eget lager tror jag.
Ja men det kan de nu mycket väl ha sagt.
Ja så att det finns i alla fall några trendiga i branschen som har eget lager.
Jag kan ju bara prata för vad jag tycker om med eget lager, men på något sätt när jag har kollat med andra personer i branschen, jag har investerat i några e-handelsbolag och folk som jag har pratat logistik med, eftersom folk vet att jag gillar logistik, då är det ganska många som har en del problem med sina tredjebatslogistiker.
Alltså att antingen det kostar väldigt mycket pengar, att de beräknar priser på lite skumma sätt, att de kanske inte optimerar hur saker står, att det ibland blir lite problematik kring vem som ska bekosta vad när de har gjort ett fel till exempel eller paketerat fel.
Jag har nästan aldrig träffat en e-handlare som säger att de tycker att deras nuvarande tredjepatslogistiklösning är toppen.
Men varför ska man då, eller vadå, så jävla krångligt är det väl inte att hantera ett lager?
Du ska hantera mera anställda, du ska se till att det är någon som täcker upp om någon anställd är sjuk.
Det finns ändå komplexiteter med eget lager, utöver att relativt många ensbolag sitter i Stockholm.
Det är enklare om man kan ha lager och kontor på samma plats.
Det blir svårare om du sitter in i stan i Stockholm, ska du då sitta utanför stan.
Vill du att ditt kontor och din retailbutik sitter ihop som många väljer att göra, då är det också svårt att be den att den ska sitta ihop med ett lager.
Det finns verkliga komplexiteter där jag tror att tredjepartslogistik är en relativt bra lösning för många.
Man hamnar på ett större fraktavtal när man är mindre.
Det gör att du får en relativt predictable kostnad på tredjepartslogistiken som du kan lära dig att leva med.
Sen är det att få ner kostnaden med ett par procentenheter genom att ta det inhouse.
När du någonstans når sig hundra miljoner kronor så tror jag att det är värdefullt att göra också.
Jag köper det, det finns massa problematik med eget lager också såklart.
Personal är givetvis knepigt och man ska fullbemanna under vissa perioder och inte under andra.
Men samtidigt så gör jag med om vissa märken som har dålig logistik under Black Week för att deras tripelllösning hanterar andra varumärken också så de är ändå långsamma.
Jag tycker bara inte att man ska ratea ut eget laget.
Jag tycker att det fyller sin funktion, speciellt om du är utanför, om du inte är i en stor stad och du har möjlighet att hyra en lokal.
Så absolut, du behöver täcka upp den andra personen.
Men har du en person som jobbar där, då får väl du åka in och jobba ibland om det är lite jobbigt.
Alltså så jävla hemskt är det inte.
Ibland när man lyssnar på Eandes poddar så ser folk såhär ja jag var nere på lagret och packade, som att det förtjänar någon sorts app-låd typ, vad fan, är du så bortkopplad från ditt företag att du inte kan packa en låda, vem fan, slappna av nu, det är inte så jävla allvarligt.
Nej, jag håller med.
Jag gillar ju principiellt vertikal integrering av bolag.
Det finns utmaningar mera men jag tror att det är väldigt starkt.
Både när det kommer till logistik och när det kommer till produktion så tycker jag att det är väldigt attraktivt med bolag som på ett eller annat sätt äger sin egen produktion också.
Det är ett annat sätt att gå liksom, att integrera uppåt i resultaträkningen.
Det här är ett sätt att vara lite längre ner.
Men nej, jag är positiv.
Jag är inte alls så negativ till eget lag som du kanske trodde.
Returer.
Ska vi gå igenom returhantering?
Det är den stora huvudverken för e-handlare.
Ja och nej.
Men det är väl det i vissa kategorier av branscher.
Jag skulle säga att många av de bra e-handelskategorierna, typ supplements, hudvård, egentligen överlag allting som konsumeras är returhantering en ganska liten del av deras totalaffär.
Medans i fashion av naturliga skäl så är returhanteringen stor.
De bolagen som tenderar att kanske gå, vara mest performance-kompatibla eller snabbväxande, de har kanske lite mer stretchiga produkter.
Det är ofta liksom här Athleisure Brands, eller NimePine har också byggt in stretch i klädmodellerna och så där, vilket tar ner returerna avsevärt.
Så det går ju att betänka redan i produktutvecklingen, hur man kan komma undan returer.
Sedan ska returerna ske, antagligen genom något form av retursystem för de flesta, alltså vare sig det är Yalo eller Returbo eller det finns ett gäng andra.
Så de tycker jag fungerar ganska bra överlag, och de flesta är ganska nöjda med de systemen.
Och sen så är ju nästa grej då, vad gör man när grejerna väl faktiskt kommer tillbaka rent fysiskt.
Och då beror det ju helt på vad man är för produktkategori, men ibland ska ju produkterna kunna säljas igen.
Ibland kan man inte sälja produkterna i en eller annan anledning, då behöver man hitta något form av kasseringssystem, där man kan återvinna de här produkterna på något sätt, är det textil så kan man ta kontakt med någon fysiskola och antingen skänka produkterna dit eller få väldigt lite betalt någonstans.
Nej men jag kan bara säga hur vi gör, sen har vi en tacksam kategori på ett sätt.
Vi har ganska få returer.
Säg att vi har, jag vet inte vad vi skulle kategoriseras om, men kanske någon procent eller två.
Så där, det är liksom inget större problem i vår värld.
Men den stora nackdelen är att det är ganska stora grejer och ganska stora värden som har retinerats.
Får vi tillbaka ett löpband som någon har monterat upp, så kanske det kostar 15 000 och så ska det ta en jävla yta om det står där.
Så att vi har satt i system att ha en flik på hemsidan med returer och sen så fort en produkt kommer in får den ett artikelnummer, den fotas på lagret, vi sänker pris, det är en returvara och folk köper, vi har sällan fler än fem returer i lager.
Utan de säljs av direkt också för att vi använder alltid samma artikelnummer och slår upp dem på.
Så att om returvaran har sålt slut men den ligger kvar i systemet i några dagar så man ser den på hemsidan, så kan folk skicka i sådana påminnelsfunktioner att när det kommer en ny retur inom en sån kategori eller en sån produkt, då får de ett påminnelsemail vilket gör att den ofta säljer slut inom typ en kvart.
Det har funkat väldigt, väldigt bra.
Ofta behöver vi inte sänka priset mer än 10% för att det är produkter som inte spelar så stor roll om någon har öppnat och skickat tillbaka.
Juniper har ju en gång om året typ sett en samplesale som vi tar alla produkter som har retunerats som vi fortfarande bedömer är i gott nog skick.
Alltså egentligen i flådels skick är väl då typiskt sett så vi kategoriserar det.
Men de ligger ändå inte kvar i den plastförpackningen de från början levererade sig.
Och säljer det via butik, oftast till 30-50% rabatt, lite beroende på vad det är för produkter och så där.
Men det skapar ändå ett awareness att det är just så att man gör egen butik, man får träffa kunder, det finns människor som kan bli introducerade till brandet som kanske inte har handlat från oss tidigare och så där.
Också ett sätt att ändå göra någonting lite kul av returhanteringen.
Ja jag håller med, men det viktigaste jag tror är att man behöver ha någonting som finns på plats, som sker löpande så att du får liksom inte börja bygga upp, börja bygga upp returer eller få ett berg av returer, så kommer du aldrig bli av med returer.
För många år sedan hade vi det som vi kallar för det svarta hålet, där ställde vi liksom alla returer och det där blev, vet inte vad det var till slut, men liksom 150 kvadrat med returer som bara stod i en hög och så tog vi reservdelar därifrån då och då.
Men det med tiden blev ju det jävligt dammigt och det blev liksom dåligt och då kan man inte sälja av det längre.
Är det tur, är den inte såld inom en vecka så behöver den börja frosta och behöver den packas isär, göra sådant till reservdelar, läggas in i systemet det sättet.
Annars kommer den aldrig sälja, den kommer bara bli dålig.
Jag tror att det är farligt att ha det.
Du skulle ha en reverse auktion så att de produkter som inte säljs börjar på 10% rabatt och sen tar den ner till 20-30% så får du se om någon gång köper i någon.
Vi gör lite grann så kan man väl säga att om en produkt har legat där i en viss tid, det är klart att vi inte efter fem dagar bara kassera produkten, men jag överdriv alltid.
Men vi sänker ner friserna först, så man får se hur länge folk vågar vänta.
Jag tänker lite krankring kundnöjdhet, lojalitet mot kunder, bygga kundklubbar och skit och allt sånt här.
Vad är din take på den världen?
Jag tror inte egentligen att det finns något bra exempel på att det är TTC Varumärken som har lyckats bygga en stark kundklubb.
Får inte Lyko ibland cred för att de har något eget ekosystem?
Absolut.
Det finns många som säger att de har lyckats bygga ett bra lojalitetssystem.
Jag tror bara att det som de upplever i väldigt stora utsträckning är att vad som händer från start när du startar ett nytt lojalitetsprogram är att du har en kunddatabas på 100.000 personer och så skickar du ut till dem och så säger du att nu startar vi ett lojalitetsprogram.
Så är det 8.000 personer, probably dina 8.000 mest lojala följare signar upp sig på det här lojalitetsprogrammet.
Sedan något år senare så gör man en mätning och så kollar man de 8.000 som är med i kundklubben, hur mycket mer pengar gör de av med oss oss gentemot de som inte befinner sig i kundklubben och sen så deklarerar någon CRM-ansvarig och säger att vår kundklubb är helt fantastisk.
För att de som är med i den här gör av med 75% mer pengar än de som inte är med.
Och så tror man att om någon signar upp sig i kundklubben så gör den personen automatiskt av med 75% mer.
Och det kanske i och för sig också är en självuppfyllande profesi i någon utsträckning.
Men hade kundklubben inte funnits så är det ganska stor chans att de här människorna hade gjort av med precis lika mycket pengar ändå, bara att de inte hade gjort det genom en app, utan i stället hade gjort det genom att de hade fått ett e-mail.
Ska du bygga en kundklubb som gör att du handlar med oss där, då måste du antingen, för att använda det gamla busswordet, antingen måste du då bygga upp någon form av stark community som gör att människor känner att om jag inte är med i den här kundklubben så är det någonting jag missar.
Jag blir inte inbjuden till deras events eller vad det nu är som gör att du känner att det är jätteviktigt som sen också ska göra det mer lojal rent produktmässigt.
Eller så måste du få bättre erbjudanden för att vara värt med i klubben.
Då ger du större rabatter till en i och för sig stänggruppmänniskor.
Man kan möjligen säga att det är en win-win relation där personen kan vara mer lojal för att de får mer rabatter.
Det kan handla oftare kanske.
Men det går också att göra via CRM.
Det är ingenting som kräver en app eller ett poängsystem utan man kan göra det rakt av.
Och så äter det ganska mycket tid att få till de här rent mjukvarumässigt och försöka hålla isär och säga att det där har väl redan skrivit ut i kundklubben.
Ska de då få ett mejl om det också via vanliga CRM eller måste du synka de systemen där det skapar mycket komplexitet?
Jag tror att det enda systemet som jag är genuint intresserad av i det här som nu jag funderar på kan vara en vinst för fler brands, det är de kundklubbarna där du måste betala upfront för att vara med för att sedan få någonting tillbaka.
The Mountain Studio, som är ett skidvarumärke, de har det, och de betalar ändå ganska lite, men du betalar 250 kronor och då hamnar du med i deras, jag tror de kallar det för Vertical Stripe, den här medlemsklubben.
Och sen helt plötsligt tar du 25% på deras site.
Det är ganska dyra produkter från början, när du får 25% så är det priset ungefär som ett vanligt skidvarumärke istället.
Men du känner att du får ut någonting av det, för det står ändå att dyrare priset är den om, och annars får du inte de där 25%.
Jag tror typ att det här är ett så här, jag har ändå lekt med tanken att Juniper skulle kunna ha något liknande att man säger att om du betalar 500 spänn up front så har du 25% på Juniper hela året.
Och jag förstår att bara någon köper någonting för 2,5 så it makes sense att betala 500 kr för att få 25% rabatt.
Men det skulle också kunna göra att vi säljer 2L handla ocean.
Om det får din hjärna att tänka att jag är ju medlem på Juniper, jag får 25% rabatt, det är klart jag måste gå och sälja min 2L handla ocean där.
Då kanske det resulterar i att du köper 2L handla ocean och så har du 8 gånger på ett år istället för 2 gånger på ett år.
Och då finns det liksom en win-win i det där någonstans att kunden upplever att de får ut ett värde, de har betalat någonting up front, de har behövt göra ett commitment utom att bara räcka upp handen liksom.
Och då kanske det faktiskt genuint förändrar deras kundbeteende i att de kommer att handla hos dig oftare.
Så det är väl den modellen jag kanske är liksom mest keen att fundera på om den kan fungera för olika bolag.
Vad rent krasst för de flesta e-handlare så släppte vi.
Extremt svårt och extremt svårt för att fungera.
Alltså det är liksom, man, de, alltså för att få en kundklubb att fungera, för att faktiskt ska fungera bra på global skala eller om du tittar över hela världen, vilka ställen som får att fungera bra, då har vi framför allt bolag som har någon form av distressed inventory, alltså inventory som måste ut.
Och det du ser då, det är flygbolag och hotell.
Hotell har tomma hotellrum som kostar nästan ingenting att serva, så att om de kan ge dig som kund till deras hotellkedja, möjligheten att bo i det där hotellrummet så kostar det hotellet några hundra lappar att serva, som du desto mer antagligen gör av med genom att dricka alkohol ner i baren på hotellet.
Så att det är typ ett wash rent kostnadsmässigt.
Och du upplever att du fått ut jättemycket värde, du fick bo i ett rum som annars hade kostat dig 4 000 kronor.
Så att du upplevde värdet i toppen kostnade dig noll.
Samma sak på flygbolaget.
Flygbolag de ger iväg gratis stolar, men de ger ju bara iväg gratis stolar om de inte tror att de kan sälja dem.
Och då har de några stolar och du upplever att helt plötsligt så tar du en extra resa fram och tillbaka till Paris på your bonus poäng och så känner du att shit vad sjukt, jag fick ut någonting som hade kostat 7 000 kronor.
Men om du inte hade tagit den där resan annars, då kostade SAS nästan ingenting att fylla upp den där stolen på planet.
Och då får du ett jättestort upplevt värde, kostar SAS ingenting.
Bra ekvation, det skapar en bra kundklubb.
Och har man av någon anledning det är en stress inventory, då kan man nästan alltid hitta en station där användaren får positiv upplevelse medan det inte kostar så mycket för företaget.
Men alla enländskt bolag säljer ju fysiska varor.
Och de här fysiska varorna de kostar pengar att köpa in och det gör att det blir alldeles riktigt den där samma wow-effekten av att du kan ge ivägvaror för det kommer med en faktiskt kostnad för dig.
Så att det är liksom en av anledningarna till att det är väldigt svårt för retailbolag att få hundklubbar att fungera.
Jag tänkte du nämnde rabatter där, kan vi snacka lite rabattkoder, rabatter, reor och liknande, vad är feeling om gränsdragningar och liknande?
Vad ska man göra?
Vad ska man börja någonstans liksom?
Många bolag gillar ju att märka ner på site.
Jag är överlag ganska positiv till att egentligen använda discount codes för DTC-bolag.
Nackdelen med discount codes är att det tenderar att bli lite mer site-wide rabatter.
Det är klart att man kan göra så här att säga att nu på Juniper site så funkar rabattkoden på sängkläder.
Det är klart att det går att göra de gränsdragningar, men det blir liksom en mer komplicerad kommunikation ur till kund.
Så rabattkoder funkar enklast ska man väl säga när man har rabatter som går site-wide.
Till exempel kanske Black Week är ett bra exempel.
Men när man märker ner priserna på site så känns det inte som att man får någonting exklusivt som kund.
Du känner dig inte utvald i termer av att du får en rabatt, utan det är 20 procent ner men det är lite så här att du har ingen uppfattning om vad priset var innan och det står ett nytt pris och du får det priset som står och det bara blir lite så här, ja okej.
Men ibland har man behov för att liksom kunna ha helt olika rabatter på olika produkter och så där och då är det probably enklast.
Det är väl en variant av det.
Den andra är väl så här, rabatter, välkomstkoder.
Jag skulle säga att det är relativt universellt nu över DTC-bolaget.
10 procent är standard i välkomstkoder.
Det finns de som är 25.
Då ser man lite sämre sign-up-rate.
Jag tror att man bara ger iväg marginalen när man kör 15 procent på välkomstkod.
Jag tror att det är bättre att prissätta så att du klarar av att ha en markdown på 7-8 procent i snitt.
Det är alltid några som inte använder välkomstkoden.
Det är väl på den sidan av ekvationen.
Har man då 10 procent i välkomstkod då är det minsta man kan ge på en rea 15 procent.
För annars ger du ingenting.
Då kanske man inte ska tro att 15 procent ger så mycket effekt för att det du ger är 5 utöver vad du kan få varje dag.
Men probably ger det någon effekt ändå.
Jag tycker att, jag gillar inte rabattkoder.
Jag stängde ner det 2013.
Sen har vi såklart reor på hemsidan och på produkter och liknande.
Men den stora problematiken för oss är att om du nämner 10% rabattkod till exempel.
Vi har vissa produkter där vi har en marginal på 14% och frakten går på 14%.
Så skulle vi sälja det med 10% rabatt så hade vi dels så hade vi sålt svinmånga för det är sådana produkter som är man ska säga vi säljer dem inte för att vi vill sälja dem utan för att kunder förväntar sig att vi ska sälja dem.
Och de säljs hos alla leverantörer och det är liksom en produkt som bara ska finnas i sortimentet.
Och hade vi sålt dem med rabatsad så går man liksom i minus, ingen vill hamna där.
Medan vi har produkter som kanske har 60 procent marginal och de har vi inget emot att göra rabatter på.
Så vi måste hela tiden, vi gör alla rabatter manuellt, även om det är på Black Week eller vanligt.
Och jag tycker att de använder reor snarare till att testa vad det korrekta priset ska vara för en vara.
Mitt mål är alltid att de 20 första produkterna, det gäller inte alltid, men de 20 första produkterna inom varje kategori ska vara utan rea på.
Om man ska komma in på sajten och börjar skrolla så ska det kännas som att det här är alltid riktiga priser.
Och sen som vi märker att en produkt säljer för långsamt eller har för avtagande, då jobbar vi med reor för att försöka hitta någon ny sorts ordinarie pris.
Så ifall vi kommer ner och vi märker att det här är mer lönsamt, vi säljer tillräckligt många fler för att vi ska kunna ligga på det här priset, då gör vi om priset på hemsidan.
Så att det blir det nya ordinarie priset, så att det finns inga rea längre utan vi bara prissätter ner produkten egentligen.
Exakt, men ni är ju lite curious på några olika sätt.
Dels att det är en så enormt varierande marginalstruktur skulle jag säga är relativt ovanligt.
För det andra så utsätts ni för en del benchmarking gentemot andra leverantörer av väldigt liknande eller ibland samma produkt.
Många DTC-varumärken har ju på något sätt sin egen produkt på sin egen site, ibland har de åtförsäljare som relativt ofta i de fallen har rabatter på deras produkter, men det är ändå inte riktigt samma problematik skulle jag säga.
Åtförsäljare kan man dels ibland skydda sig mot genom paketförsäljning eller bundles av olika slag.
Det kan göra att du kan ha möjlighet att ge permanent rabatter utan att det känns så rabattigt men liksom i paketförsäljning.
Det andra jag tänkte på där var att ni har möjlighet att ni har ett inventoriaprodukt.
Om du märker att någon produkt går rätt kast så slutar du köpa in den produkten och sen köper du in någon annan produkt som du tror kommer att sälja bättre.
Men relativt många bolag, framförallt kanske Modvärlden, har ju massa drops.
I de där dropsen så är det svårt i förväg att veta exakt vad som kommer att sälja bra och vad som kommer att sälja dåligt för att det är ett nytt drop relativt förra året.
Så sitter du hela tiden på en svans av produkter som inte är great för försäljningen alls.
Där hamnar man ju i stationen när det nästan är omöjligt att inte rea ut, eller möjligen om det är produkter som går att flytta på om man accepterar lägre effektivitet i marknadsföringen.
Om man i vanliga fall är beredd att betala 100 lapp för 200 kronor i omsättning, så kanske man säger att man på de här produkterna, för att vi ska slippa ge 50-70% rabatt på dem under sommaren, så är vi beredda att betala 150 kronor för 200 kronor i försäljning.
Det kanske inte ens är lönsamt, men det kanske ändå är bättre än att erbjuda 70% rabatt, både ur ett varumärksperspektiv och ibland även ekonomiskt.
Vad är det som stoppar, om man har den problematiken där man måste testa produkter, att man måste köpa in på chansning eller vad man ska kalla det.
Jag fattar det låter ju skitjobbigt liksom.
Jag är väldigt glad att jag slipper jobba på det sättet.
Varför jobbar man inte med dubbla hemsidor, så att man har en helt annan prisbild på en annan hemsida, eller att man jobbar med återförsäljare där man kan dumpa ut.
Jobbar man så?
Jo men det gör man väl absolut.
Det är väl många som har återförsäljare knyta till sig.
Dubbla hemsidor vet jag inte, tror jag någon bolag som gör.
Som heter typ Galne Gunnar's kläder, och så dumpar man sina priser.
Det finns så många av DTC-bolagen som jag kan peka på, som jag tror skulle vara helt bekväma med att sätta upp Galne Gunnar's kläder vid sidan om.
Men man kan även A-B testa prispunkt på en och samma sajt, det är fullt görbart liksom.
Jag tror att många, framför allt de modbolagen, de ser inte riktigt prissättning som så mekaniskt.
Sen säger jag inte att det inte är det, men jag tror att de inte riktigt uppfattar det.
Jag fattar inte vad mina rum är det.
Jag tror inte alltid att de tänker på att om vi säljer de här jeansen för 1500 kronor eller 1800 kronor så kommer demand på något sätt att förändras avsevärt.
Men det kommer det ju absolut.
När du pratar pris, ofta med lite mer varumärkesdrivna bolag, deras motargument när du säger att det vore bättre om vi kom ner 200 lappar i pris, så blir det alltid svaret att om du tänker i en kille som kommer in på vår site, tror du verkligen att det spelar någon roll om jeansen kostar 1800 kronor eller 1600 kronor?
Då blir det alltid ens egna reaktioner.
Du kanske inte spelar så stor roll för att du tänker i en människa framför dig som heter Marcus.
Just för Marcus spelar det nog inte så stor roll.
Men eftersom det inte såg du marknadsföring ut under marknadsföring mot tusentals människor som kommer in på sajten.
I stora grupper så spelar det roll om en produkt kostar 1800 kronor eller 1600 kronor.
Människor är lite mer i köp och näring, den kostar 200 lappar mindre.
Och det där är ofta så här, människor gillar att tänka på en individ, men i stora grupper så spelar saker roll på ett annat sätt, om man gör för att känna in det ut.
Om man någonstans ska snacka lite prissättning i det också, så jag upplever att folk inte justerar sina priser tillräckligt mycket.
Vi brukar jobba från båda håll egentligen.
I princip varje vecka så justerar jag ett gäng priser uppåt några procent.
Så kollar jag på data på dem ifall försäljningen sjunker eller blir sämre över två månaders tid.
Vi har ju ganska långsamt inventarie, det spelar ingen roll.
Vi behöver inte anpassa oss till några drops och sånt där.
Så då gör vi någon sorts successiv höjning på produkter för att se.
Så länge det inte påverkar försäljningen så är det ju positivt att öka några tio där eller några 50 lappar där eller vad man ska säga.
Och sen så gör vi egentligen samma sak på andra ställen.
Om vi ser att produkter som vi tror borde sälja bättre, inte säljer, så skiftar vi de priserna successivt nedåt.
Det är ganska små increment.
1800-1600 är ganska mycket.
Man kan börja med 1800-1790, sen kan man testa 1749-1690.
Det finns ganska många.
Ganska märkligt kan jag tycka att det ofta finns lite bizarra sweetspots för vissa produkter.
Vi har ett löpande till exempel som jag har testat upp och ner i ett par år.
Det ska kosta 10 490 för det är vad det löpandet ska kosta.
Om jag höjer det till 10 690 som är procentuellt 1,7 procent eller vad det kan bli, så försvinner en tredjedel av försäljningen.
Och sänker det med 1000 spänn så händer ingenting.
Det är verkligen en sweetspot på 10 490.
Det är jättebizarret.
Jag upplever att folk inte testar.
Man tänker att jag har en reaperiod, jag har inte en reaperiod.
Nu ska jag höja med 10 procent sitewide.
Istället för att ta en produkt i taget, du har tid, det är okej att lägga lite tid en gång i veckan på att kolla lite produkter.
Det kan göra ganska mycket.
Absolut.
Jag tror att dynamisk prissättning överlag är ganska underpenetrerat i e-handel.
Jag tror att vi kommer att se mer av det framåt.
Vi pratade om Nike tidigare och Nike gör det väldigt, väldigt bra.
Du kan gå in på vilken skomodell som helst på Nikes hemsida och så kan du se att du får betala 19.90 i orange och så får du betala 17.90 i blått och så får du betala en annan prispunkt och en annan färg.
Av den enkla anledningen, obviously, att de där lite fulare färgerna, de säljer inte lika bra.
Är du villig att köpa Nikes fulare modeller, då får du 25 procents rabatt på samma skor.
Ja, exakt.
För mig när jag ska köpa löpskor, det spelar mig ingen roll hur mina löpskor ser ut.
Jag söker en funktion, så jag går in på deras sajt, jag väljer en modell och så tar jag den fulaste av den modellen och då får jag allt i rabatt.
Men jag tror att Nike tycker det är toppen, de är ju bra med den modellen och alla är nöjda.
Jag har också en liknande modell, jag går in på Merkels yrkeskläder, kollar om det finns några skor där man kan springa i och branda upp, går det då tar jag de skorna.
Man har sin stil, man har sin stil.
Kan vi prata lite CRM-system?
Folk snackar, jag kan egentligen bara ett namn och det är Klavio, men jag vet inte vad det betyder.
Jag har aldrig reflekterat över det, det är olikt men jag brukar reflektera över sådant där.
Du har Rule som är svenskt, som skulle jag säga är ganska enkelt, men kanske lite mindre feature-tätt.
Sen så går du upp till Klavio som är absolut det mest prevalenta systemet bland DTC-varumärken.
Det är en lagom kombination av att du kan göra ganska mycket och det är inte jättekomplicerat.
Så går du till Voyado som är ytterligare ett steg mer komplicerat.
Men liksom med de fördelarna som det kommer med ökad komplexitet.
Man ser väl i större utsträckning att väldigt stora e-handlare, väldigt stora behöver inte vara så stort nödvändigtvis, men några hundra miljoner uppåt.
Där är Voyado ett vanligare system för e-handlare mellan 50 och 3-400 så är Klavio väldigt stort.
Och Rule skulle jag säga är att ha några e-handlare som har valt väldigt kostnadsmedvetet på DTC-sidan.
Och sen ser man en hel del multibrandbutiker gå med Rule för att multibrand har ofta långa lister av människor men får ut ganska låg revenue per namn på sin lista.
Och då finns det ett stort värde i att hålla ner kostnaden på listolekarna för att det knyter in i kostnadsmodellen.
Det är väl det man ser.
Klavio är väl det vi kommer i kontakt med absolut mest.
Jag försöker nu få ner igenom 90% av kunderna jag jobbar med kanske har klavio.
Finns det något system som, jag vill inte säga om det finns på svenska marknader, men finns det något sådant här system som folk använder som du är såhär som börjar använder för det kommer inte att vara bra.
För mig är det lite grann samma sak som med Shopify här.
Det är för oss i alla fall som byrå som jobbar med många brands, det är otroligt behagligt när någon jobbar med Shopify.
Man kan argumentera om fördelarna med Shopify, men en av fördelarna i alla fall, det är att de flesta jobbar med Shopify.
Det gör att det är ganska lätt att bygga system runt Shopify.
Det är samma sak med Klavio, det är ganska lätt för oss att komma in och hjälpa en kund som jobbar med Klavio.
Vi är inte egentligen en CRM-byrå, men vi lutar oss in ganska mycket och hjälper våra kunder med CRM ändå.
Men om kunden är på vår ja då så blir det direkt lite svårare.
Då blir vi mindre hjälpsamma för att tösken för oss att hjälpa till är högre.
Det är ganska skönt om du är på plattformar där många andra som är i din station är, för då kan du prata med vem som helst och fråga hur gör ni med det här?
Hur löser ni det?
Det är någon som har det problemet som du har garanterat, så då kan du få hjälp med den grejen.
Därför är det så så här, ibland när man sitter och diskuterar plattformsval och kundtjänstsystem och CRM och allt vad det är, så en av lösningen är att bara inte engineer för mycket, utan ta det som typ alla andra kör, för att det är också rätt praktiskt.
Ja, apropå sidosystem så, det finns ju en del sådana sidosystem, jag tänkte bara kolla, det finns ett som heter DEMA som jag vet att du har koll på i alla fall.
Ja, absolut.
Att köpa till system som ska effektivisera din affär, eller vad vi ska kalla det, är det någonting som man behöver tänka på?
När behöver man börja tänka på det?
Och vad är rimliga system att köpa till?
Jag tror att, jag nämnde snabbt kundkännssystem innan, jag tror att kundkännssystem är väldigt värt att köpa in relativt tidigt, för det kostar inte så jättemycket.
Jag tänkte säga, vad har man om man inte har ett kundkännssystem?
En e-mail-låda liksom.
Ja, det är ju dåligt.
Det är en dålig lösning liksom.
Det är mycket bättre att ha ett kundkännssystem så att du kan ha tickets och tracka dem och det finns liksom flaggningssystem och så vidare.
Alla funkar lite olika men i realiteten är ungefär likadant som varandra.
Och jag tror att framförallt nu när AI liksom blir viktigare och viktigare att få in i kundkännssystemen, har du gmail och ska försöka liksom ja men gemmen är inne i gmail eller kundkännssystem, jättedålig idé så mycket mycket bättre att liksom köpa in ett kundkännssystem, gå med någon av de stora, antingen så typ gorgeous är stort, sandesk är stort.
Mimir har vi precis bytt till med Uniper som heter Norskt system, som är liksom ett AI first system som vi valde och tro på liksom.
Och det verkar som att teamet verkligen uppskattar dem, vi har bara varit igång i typ två veckor sen, så det kan inte till fullo säga att allting är fantastiskt, men det verkar som att teamet...
Ni har inte behövt söka efter två gamla ärenden än.
Nej, men det verkar som att teamet överlag är väldigt positiva, relativt gorgeous som vi var på innan.
Gorgeous skulle jag nog säga är kanske det vanligaste systemet.
Själv så att vi bytte till gorgeous var för att det är det som är mest Shopify native, det pratar om alla system och det som däremot gorgeous inte var, var att även om man går till deras hemsida så står det nu att det här är kundkännssystemet för AI, men det det är är att det här var ett gammalt kundkännssystem och sen så har de försökt att lappa ihop det med AI i efterhand.
Men Myr har byggt ett kundkännssystem med AI i botten och sen så liksom bygger de på ovan på det och det blir väldigt stor skillnad i användarupplevelsen.
Så att det tror jag är väl värt att investera i i alla fall.
Sen så du pratade ju om DEMA då som är ett typ business intelligence system skulle jag säga.
Nu gör även DEMA kreativ analys.
Jag använder inte personligen DEMA till kreativ analys.
Vi använder Motion för kreativ analys över alla våra konton.
En av de grejerna som byrå är lite opraktiskt med DEMA är att DEMA köps in av varumärkena själva.
Vilket är en helt rimlig väg för dem att gå rent kommersialiseringsmässigt.
Men det gör ju att jag som byrå, jag har kanske sju kunder som använder DEMA.
Och då kan inte jag bygga våra system runt DEMA.
För jag kan bara ha det på några kunder.
Jag behöver liksom hitta andra vägar för att komma till analysen.
Så vi har liksom DEMA på några kunder.
Det är Lifetimely på några kunder som är en Shopify-plugin som fungerar relativt bra, liksom inte riktigt lika avancerat som DEMA, men ändå funkar ganska bra.
GetClar har vi någon kund som är på.
Ja, jag missar säkert något ytterligare bysystem.
Det finns även de som bara har i typ Click eller sådär också.
Det finns lite olika sådana system.
Jag tycker att det är väl värt att ha ett Business Intelligence-system där jag vill kunna fråga frågan vad var vår GP3 igår och få ett svar på den frågan som är någorlunda trovärdigt.
Det levererar typiskt sett inte Shopify på ett bra sätt.
Det är inte någon av webbplattformarna som levererar det på ett bra sätt.
Då behöver man få ut det i ett Business Intelligence-system och man behöver sätta sig och gå igenom sina gamla årsredovisningar eller månadsredovisningar och försöka anpassa systemet så att de närmar sig varandra eller man åtminstone förstår varför det står lite annorlunda i redovisningen mot vad det står i systemet.
Så att man kan lita på systemet och att det i alla fall typ säger 95 procent korrekt.
Så att om vi tillsammans efter helgen säger att i helgen tjänade vi såhär mycket pengar, då är du överens om att vi tjänade såhär många pengar.
Sen kan vi säga, sen kan man liksom vara ledsen på varandra eller glada på varandra för att det har gått bra eller dåligt.
Men vi är i alla fall överens om hur mycket vi har tjänat.
När man inte är överens om vad man har tjänat, då blir diskussionerna på fel plats.
Då sitter man och diskuterar om datan är korrekt istället för att diskutera och ta för actions framåt.
Så därför att ha en source of truth tror jag är viktigt.
Så därför absolut att investera i ett sådant system någonstans.
Någon sorts avslutande dialog eller fråga, vad är det e-handlare, vilka roller är underbemannade hos e-handlare?
Finns det någonting som e-handlare är konsekvent dåliga på att hantera?
Ja, det finns det nog.
Jag tror att när vi satt upp Orange Juice så var en av de grejerna som vi identifierade var att varumärken har en önskan om att deras marknadsföring ska fungera bra såklart.
Alla byråer tror jag ändå gör sitt bästa för att leverera det att varumärken vill.
Jag tror inte att det finns ondsinta byråer därute.
Det finns ingen byrå som bara vill tjäna lite pengar på näriva e-handlar.
Jag vet några som...
Men man har ju...
Alltså om man, men när det är själv...
Alltså det är self-serving att leverera en bra tjänst som byrå för att då får du behålla dina kunder.
Så jag tror ändå att alla byråer försöker sig till att leverera en bra tjänst.
Men jag tror att problemet är att varumärken ofta då kommer till en byrå och så säger de kan ni hjälpa oss med marknadsföring, vi vill gärna växa och det är gärna mer lönsamt.
Ungefär den specien kommer ganska ofta.
Så sitter byrån på sin sida och så säger de att ni hade tre ROAs förut och vi ska försöka upprätthålla tre ROAs, vi ska försöka spända lite mer pengar eller vad det nu är.
Och där emellan uppstår ett gap som liksom inte riktigt någon äger.
Att vad är det för KPIs som vi ska följa, vad är det för KPIs som faktiskt driver att det finns mer pengar på kundens bankkonto, att det finns ökad lönsamhet, att vi säkerställer tillväxt, när är det värt att slå av på marknadsföringstakten, till fördel för lönsamare kunder, när borde vi accelerera.
Och hela det pusselet, där tror jag att byrån ofta tänker att det är brandet som styr när vi ska accelerera eller inte.
Brandet sitter ofta och tänker att det borde nå en av våra byror att ta ansvar för.
Och så uppstår det ett gap.
När vi startade Orange Juice var det som att vi sa att vi täcker det där gapet, vi äger det gapet, det kanske går dåligt, men ifall det går dåligt är det vårt fel.
Då kan kunden välja att säga hej då till oss.
Det är aldrig någon ambiguity i att vi kommer att leverera en point of view på exakt hur mycket pengar vi tycker band ska spendera, till vilka effektivitetsnivåer och vad vi ska göra för att förbättra den effektiviteten.
Sen kan inte vi eller någon annan utlova resultat, men vi tar i alla fall ansvar för det gapet.
Det tror jag liksom är någonting som bolag generellt sätter dåliga på.
Om du har en proffs CFO, om vi ska kalla det för det liksom, och de börjar ju ofta komma in någonstans mellan 50 och 100 miljoner, där brukar man ofta få någon som är finansiellt ansvarig.
De har ofta inte en stark förståelse för hur marketing fungerar och hur demand drivs i ett DTC-bolag.
Så har du en CMO som också ofta dyker upp där någonstans.
De har istället ofta inte en jättestark förståelse över hur en resultaträkning fungerar.
Även när man har en C-suite som sitter och pratar med varandra så uppstår det ofta ett gap internt i organisationen.
Så kommer en budget från en CFO som en CMO blir ombedd att försöka leverera på.
Sen kanske den budgeten är helt omöjlig att leverera på och sen är man missnade med varandra och förstår inte riktigt vad som händer.
Jag tror att det där är en roll att hitta människor som förstår marketing och finans i alla fall.
Det var det gapet vi identifierade i bolag som gjorde att vi satte upp Orange Juice.
Sen finns det säkert andra roller jag tror att...
Vi har lite här under den här serien pratat om ups and downs med varumärk och så där.
Jag tror att många varumärken känner att de gärna skulle ha någon som är starkare på varumärke internt.
När det kommer till att, hur ska vi connecta till vår community?
Hur ska vi uttrycka vårt varumärke?
Hur ska vi ställa till att vi bygger långsiktigt värde?
Det är en svår roll.
Det är svårt att rekrytera för, svårt att veta om det blir rätt och liksom, även efter att ha haft en sådan person på roll under en period så är det inte riktigt lätt att veta om det blir bra eller inte, utan det tar lång tid.
Så det är också en roll som är svår.
Men ja, nej.
Och sen överlag bara så tror jag att att bygga ett team som jobbar ganska hårt och tycker att det är kul att lära sig, det är svårt också.
Och någonting som jag tycker ganska ofta är att man känner att det inte riktigt finns den här glöden.
Lönebilden är ganska nedtryckt i e-handels Sverige.
Och det finns väl en risk att det kanske inte alltid lockar till sig människor som vill verkligen gneta på.
Och det, ja, ibland lyckas man och då är det toppen.
Man har också en mismatch mellan, det låter ju fancy att vara e-commerce manager eller CFO på det där e-handelsbolaget, men om du sätter 50 miljoner så kommer du kanske ta världens dyraste CFO om det jämför med, alltså, ja.
For sure liksom.
Ja, och det är, men precis, det kan vara en mismatch lite sådär i rollbeskrivningar.
På ett sätt är ju rollbeskrivningar gratis att ge iväg, men, eller titlar då liksom.
Men på ett annat sätt så kanske det också skapar en situation där människor känner sig som mer senior än vad de kanske helst skulle göra liksom.
Man behöver en hög grad av operationalitet på små team.
Det funkar inte med man som är middle managers liksom, utan alla behöver faktiskt göra saker.
Ja, ja.
Jag kan verkligen, ja, vi börjar typ nu hamna i en situation där folk gör olika saker.
Alltså innan har ju alla bara löst allting.
Alltså det är verkligen, alla löser allt.
Vad heter det?
All konstnärer egentligen är alla bara någon sorts assistenter till varandra.
Om man ska vara helt krass.
Ja, men Jakob ett enormt tack för att du har varit här och spotat kunskap i fyra timmar.
Jag hoppas folk har fått med sig någonting.
Stort tack, otroligt kul.
Det var verkligen som du sa då när du var på vägen, att det känns inte som att det varit så svårt att prata fyra timmar till.
Jag tänkte ändå innan att fyra timmar är länge, men det känns som att vi ändå har fått hugga vissa konversationer kort längs här.
Exakt, jag tänker att vi gör en snabb plugg till, om det kallas så.
Men du har din egen podd nu som, när det här släpps så har den nog gått ut för om typ sex veckor, då kanske den har kommit live.
Exakt, Masters of E-commerce, den får ni kolla upp på Spotify.
Jag har dessutom fått förmånen att ha Björn Poulans Spenger som första gäst.
Han är ju ofta intervjuare i framtidens e-handel, men väldigt kul att få intervjua honom om hans förehavanden och investeringar.
Så det kan vara ett kul avsnitt att börja med.
Är du snäll mot honom eller är du elak mot honom?
Frågade du honom hur mycket hans gäster mutar honom?
Hur långt går du i din analys?
Vi satt ju och spelade in i hans poddstudio, det känns hårt att sätta dit honom där.
Jag kommer behöva till crack på att intervjua honom en gång till längre fram.
Jag fattar.
In och lyssna på den.
Stort tack Jakob.
Stort tack, hej.
Jag har också en liknande modell.
Jag går in på merkesyrkeskläder, kollar om det finns några skor där man kan springa i och branda upp.
Går det då tar jag de skorna.
Man har sin stil.